Mobile gettin that is what the changes
to Google search algorithm are being
called rankings will now take into
account how mobile friendly a website
really is it's a reflection of the
incredibly fast growth of mobile search
with a number of mobile search users
expected to equal computer search users
by 2018 so in just three short years
joining us now is Bloomberg intelligence
Paul Sweeney with his take on this and
it's just mirroring the time's right we
do most of our searches a lot of our
searches of mobile phone so how big a
deal is this I think this is going to be
a big deal I mean you know Google
changes or makes changes to its
algorithm fairly frequently and whenever
it does there is a shakeout period there
are winners and losers whenever google
that does that this is particularly
noteworthy I think because it's really
making you know a commitment to mobile
and mobile searches and the fact that
consumers are spending more and more of
their time on mobile devices interacting
with Google sourcing their google
searches more through mobile devices
then through a desktop so Google wants
to make sure that the search results
that it serves up are most relevant for
these mobile users and so of course web
sites around the world have to make sure
that their websites have a very good
mobile you know angle to them and that
they will actually come up and show up
well on the search results so again
there will be winners and losers I think
some of the smaller mom-and-pop websites
out there might be a little bit at risk
maybe but I mean frankly speak you mean
you know the cost of having a mobile
having a website or coming down right
and having a mobile website it doesn't
cost that much extra to try to tailor
your content to the mobile you know to
the mobile platform right so is anyone
really going to cry out and say this is
unfair well I think there's certain web
web sites out there certain website
designers that have really taken a
mobile first approach over the last
couple of years and I think those will
probably end up servicing probably the
best on the Google search results under
the new algorithm those websites that
necessarily have not done done that have
not made the investment yeah on the back
end might be a little bit slow to adapt
so I think you can see some of those
operators say listen these this new
search algorithm really disadvantages of
us and we you know we probably have to
invest in our business to try to with
that it'll cost us
adapter yes so is this going to have an
impact at all Paul on other browsers I
mean is it you know like this has
changed the game at all a year i think
so i think it does i mean google with
their seventy-five percent market share
searches in the u.s. you know over
eighty-five percent globally they
clearly drive kind of the bus here and
they really have always been on the
cutting edge i think of search
algorithms and others tend to follow but
again as you mentioned the outset this
is really just a reflection what's
really happening on the internet whether
its e-commerce or media it's all going
mobile and if you don't have a mobile
strategy you're really going to be
letting your out a lot right okay
speaking on mobile strategy yahoo is
reporting after the bell today so what
are we gonna hear well i think the
street you know I think the street
definitely applauded Marissa Meyer and a
management team for really efficiently
monetizing part of their Asian
investments most notably Ali Baba so
that's arguably behind yahoo now their
pressure is going to build even more on
Marissa Meyer and our management team to
really operate the basics of the
business and that just simply means
growing the top-line revenue and one of
the challenges to google for to Yahoo
because they have in fact been been
lagging is they do not historically have
had a very strong mobile strategy mobile
presence and that is really hurt their
ability right they haven't been mobile
first that that's right right exactly oh
great to see you so much Paul Sweeney of
Bloomberg intelligence